let's get into the episode huh yeah this
is a new segment
called shoot your shot and it's
self-explanatory
convince that to our eyes
and i am from phoenix arizona uh first
and foremost i just want to say that i
absolutely adore you guys and love the
content that you produce every week
um this is hands down my favorite
podcast and i look forward to listening
to it
every friday morning as soon as i get to
work um i was actually introduced to
your podcast from this guy
that i have really been into for quite
some time now uh his name is paul he's
absolutely amazing
and damn near perfect to me so i thought
what better way
to try to shoot my shot than to
hopefully get his attention here on the
podcast
hopefully it works and hopefully my
friends here on king and the sting will
co-sign for me
uh but paul if you're listening
[Laughter]
oh paulie want a crap girl
now was that a filter because her teeth
were blue too or am i going [ __ ]
crazy
i believe she's got an xc in this
barbecue sauce
were her teeth blue there's a little
ecstasy in that yeah a little bit in
there you know
her teeth were blue right yes no and her
hair's blue
no it isn't brendan it's like a tinge i
think she's got a filter on okay i think
it's a fun okay
so she's not a prisoner okay so she's
looking for paul man i like it
we gotta get uh paul if you're out there
send us your response
either way oh well it's like it's like
shoot your shot connection shoot your
shot please yeah i respect you polly
want a cracker come get it dog yeah
and she's she's prepared either way if
he's not into it
she she knew that's the chance she's
taken dang okay
there you go just like that wife out
there
[Laughter]
you hit somebody with a high heel [ __ ]
happens that's the chance you take it
man
i'm sure i'm sure if polly don't want
the cracker she's going to get a bunch
of other
dudes in them dms she might she might
not uh but she is
yes yeah yeah do 120 look at her
yeah beautiful girl yeah and she can uh
i'll have to find out if she's cool with
us giving out her instagram in case paul
says no
oh i think she is i think she's
definitely attractive i just mean she
do we have enough creepy guys out there
that would be just senator dms i guess
we do i'm going to go ahead and say yes
there you go survey says
yes checking my dms yes
[Music]
is